[Music]
the strength of a family like the
strength of an army lies in its loyalty
to each
other when everything goes to hell the
people who stand by you without
flinching they are your
[Music]
family
family is not an important thing it's
[Music]
everything it didn't matter how big your
house was it mattered that there was
love in
[Music]
it
family means nobody gets left behind or
forgotten parents are like God you want
to know they're out there and you want
them to think well of you but you really
only call when you need
[Music]
something
all happy families are alike each
unhappy family is unhappy in its own
[Music]
way families are the compass that guides
us they are the inspiration to reach
Great Heights and our comfort when we
falter
[Music]
family faces are magic mirrors looking
at people who belong to us we see the
past present and
[Music]
future home isn't where you're from it's
where you find light when all grows
[Music]
dark in family life love is the oil that
eases friction the cement that binds the
music that brings
Harmony the bond that links thinks your
true family is not one of blood but of
respect and joy in each other's
life the family is the test of freedom
because the family is the only thing
that the free man makes for himself and
by
[Music]
himself a happy family is a taste of
Heaven to
come you are the bows from which your
children as living arrows are sent
[Music]
forth you don't choose your family they
are God's gift to you as you are to
them
[Music]
in every conceivable manner the family
is a link to our past a bridge to our
[Music]
future having a place to go is a home
having somebody to love is a family
having both is a
blessing
[Music]
in time of test family is
best show me a family of readers and I
will show you the people who move the
world
parents were the only ones obligated to
love you from the rest of the world you
had to earn
[Music]
it some people are worth melting
for home is not a place it's people if
you go back there after your people are
gone then all you can see is what is not
there
[Music]
anymore family and friends are hidden
treasures seek them and enjoy their
[Music]
riches the only Rock I know that stays
steady the only institution I know that
works is the
[Music]
family friends are the family you
choose stick to the basics hold on to
your family and friends they will never
go out of fashion
the love of family and the admiration of
friends are much more important than
wealth and
[Music]
privilege you need a rock solid
foundation of friends and family to keep
you where you need to
[Music]
be
the informality of family life is a
blessed condition that allows us to
become our best while looking our
worst there is no doubt that it is
around the family and the home that all
the greatest virtues are created
strengthened and
[Music]
maintained
a man should never neglect his family
for
[Music]
business a family is a bunch of people
who keep confusing you with someone you
were as a
[Music]
kid being a family means you are a part
of something wonderful it means you will
love and be loved for the rest of your
[Music]
life